okay let's now talk about what's going
on
with what could maybe be and could have
been
a real commission to investigate what
happened on the day of the trump riots
january
6th 2021. there's a new piece
in huffpost very interesting piece by
jennifer bendery called
the 139 republicans who lied
fueled an insurrection and then voted to
cover it up
she writes last week 35 senate
republicans
killed a bipartisan effort to create an
independent commission to investigate
the january 6th insurrection at the u.s
capitol arguably
the greatest attack on american
democracy since the civil war
it would indeed have been bipartisan
remember that that's really important
some republicans are saying it would
have been a partisan witch hunt it was
going to be
ten members of the house five democrats
five republicans
five chosen by democrats five chosen by
republicans
the chair of the commission would have
been a democrat and the vice chair would
have been a republican
because democrats control the house
after all and all subpoenas issued
would have had to be signed off on by
both the democratic chair
and the republican vice chair it was
going to be the closest you could have
to a truly bipartisan commission many
republicans saying it was going to be a
partisan witch hunt
um she goes on to write a week earlier
135 175 house republicans
oppose creating the commission too why
would any u.s
senator or member of congress oppose an
independent commission
to investigate what led to a deadly
attack on the u.s capitol one aimed
squarely at undermining american
democracy and the peaceful transfer of
power
the reasons are as cynical as they are
obvious and this is the exact analysis
we gave last week
most of these republicans lied about the
presidential election being stolen from
donald trump
that lie helped motivate a white
supremacist mob of trump supporters
to smash their way into the capital some
with plans to kill house speaker nancy
pelosi vice president mike pence and
others
to stop congress from certifying joe
biden's electoral win
republicans don't want a respected panel
of experts publicly connecting the dots
heading into the 2022 elections this is
an
additional part that's interesting they
also don't want to get on trump's bad
side
by supporting a commission that would
show in detail how his lie
incited an attack on democracy that left
five people dead
hundreds of police officers injured and
countless others traumatized
there are two things going on here
republicans know
these republicans the ones that were
doing the inciting and that voted
against
these republicans know if the
investigation
is done properly they will probably be
in the spotlight as part of the problem
the people doing the commission some of
the people doing the commission
will really be culpable themselves of
what the commission is investigating
that's part one
part two we're going to talk about this
later there is every indication
that yes not only is donald trump
interested in running in 2024
it's probably his nomination to take or
decline
in other words there is every indication
that many or most republicans still
believe and why wouldn't they it's borne
out in the polls
republicans still accurately believe
that trump is the head of the party
trump will play king maker in 2022 trump
is about to restart rallies trump is
still pushing these audits
and trump is likely to try to run in
2024
if a health issue keeps him out of it as
many of you write to me and say okay
but that is likely the reality and so
why would you get on trump's bad side by
voting in favor of this because trump
holds grudges and trump is vindictive
and he will remember
one more piece from this article
jennifer bendery writes it gets uglier
their party is counting on people to
keep believing the lie
republican-led state legislatures all
over the country are using the lie to
justify
quickly passing bills to significantly
restrict voting in ways that would
disproportionately
hurt communities of color just this year
state lawmakers have already issued at
least 389 restrictive bills in 49 states
and passed
22 restrictive laws in 14 states
it's no coincidence that the four states
where republicans have filed the most
bills aimed at restricting voting
georgia arizona michigan and
pennsylvania
were some of the closest states in the
2020 presidential election as 5
38 notes all four of those states went
for biden and have republican-controlled
legislatures which makes them especially
ripe for new voting restrictions so
three reasons here really why you are
seeing this republican opposition
one the commission would likely find
that
they were part of the problem two they
want to stay in donald trump's good
graces because it seems trump is going
to have power and control in the
republican party for a long period of
time to come at least through the 2022
election
if he fails to pick the winners in 2022
things may change but at least through
2022 and number three
if they can continue uh putting off
a real investigation into what happened
which would of course
uncover that the election was fine the
election wasn't rigged
joe biden just won they
lose the ability if that is made public
through the commission
to keep justifying these further
restrictions on voting
that they're passing in many states so
democrats
need to move forward with the probe
without any republicans there's a couple
of ways that it could happen
it would then actually be a partisan
commission now i know what you might be
thinking
you know david republicans falsely say
we don't want to participate in this
because it's going to be partisan
and then as a result democrats just move
forward and it is partisan
that is that that is of course what they
are going to claim
but the benefits of doing the commission
by far outweigh
claims from republicans that it's
partisan because they were going to make
those claims anyway
and we do need to see democrats do
something the headlines continue coming
that democrats aren't holding them
accountable and
to a degree it's true now so far they've
been trying to just get the votes to do
it with republicans
it's not clear that that's going to
happen they've got to figure out a move
for a way to move forward on their own
it'll be called partisan either way so
i'd rather the commission be done
in some way shape or form than not let
me know what you think and we're going
to have more on this on the david pakman
show
instagram which you can find at david
pakman show check it out and we'll be
back right after this
during the pandemic and even at this
point i try to avoid
physically visiting a doctor's office
unless i really have to and that's why
i love our sponsor steady md primary
care
you take a quiz you get matched with a
licensed primary care physician who's a
good fit for you
you have a one hour virtual appointment
and you start
a meaningful relationship with your new
doctor after that
your doctor is available to you anytime
by text phone and video chat
and unlike other services this isn't
some random doctor on call
each doctor at steady md has a limited
number of patients so they can give you
the personal attention you deserve
they can help you with anything your
primary care doctor
normally would healthy diet managing
conditions weight loss sleep
depression anxiety you don't need
insurance it's just 99
a month with absolutely no other fees or
co-pays for visits
take the free quiz and see which doctor
is a perfect fit for you
go to steadymd.com pacman there's no
risk
no long-term commitment the link is
right underneath this video